Doron Reuveni, thank you so much
for joining me on the show.
My pleasure.
Really great to have you.
You're the CEO of Applause now.
A fantastic company that I actually,
I've been following quite closely
ever since my time in the IDF
and building software myself.
But I'd love to get started
by getting to know you a little bit better.
How you've come to Applause
to be the CEO,
you actually were also
the board member of RunKeeper, right?
Yeah, I was
until it was actually sold
to ASICS at the time.
So, I do like to take a few
independent board seats
and help young entrepreneurs and CEOs
grow their company.
And I did it a few times.
One was RunKeeper, I think three years ago.
And one was GrabCAD,
that was another company
that I was on the board on -
Well, I love RunKeeper.
I actually use it almost on a daily basis
to run.
So, as soon as I saw it
I got so excited.
Doron, tell me,
what is it like to be a board member
of a sort of B2C company where
there's so much engagement with the users
and the growth is tremendous.
What is your role as a board member
for a company like RunKeeper?
Yeah. So RunKeeper is actually
a very good example
because first of all,
for me it was very interesting
because they had a great founder.
I always love working
with a great founder.
I just give you an example.
You know, he was the first one
that came with a mobile app
that tracks your running
and creates a running community.
And at the beginning, he had no funding.
So, he was actually running
the Boston Marathon with this,
like, iPhone outfit.
So, he was so passionate about it.
He was running with an iPhone app.
And you can probably look it up.
It's actually pretty interesting -
I'm gonna put it right over here
with my tremendous editing.
So, right over here,
there's gonna be a picture of him
running with the iPhone outfit.
Yeah, I can probably send it to you.
We're still good friends.
And for me,
it was a very interesting type of endeavor
because my background
is in B2B and enterprise software.
And RunKeeper is obviously a B2C company.
And actually one of the first one
that focused on
mobile application in iPhone.
And it was for me a very good endeavor
into the metrics and analytics
of a big company.
And one of the reasons
that I joined is
gain some more experience
in the B2C space,
but also kind of help RunKeeper,
because what happened to them is
they was the first one
that actually came out,
but they were not,
they were getting their lunch
eaten a little bit by companies
like Strava that came
from the cycling world.
And there was a few other examples,
a few companies that were acquired
by Under Armour, etc, etc.
So we had to kind of, me and the investors, had to
figure out a way together with the CEO
to put the company on a trajectory
to continued growth and success.
And eventually we did that.
And that was actually sold to ASICS,
which is a running shoe company
I guess. That was a great success for them
to ... and the team.
And now they're basically part
of the digital,
I would say digital agency of ASICS.
So, everything digital for ASICS is
actually going through the RunKeeper.
Wow.
My job as an independent board member,
and I think this is very important
for CEOs and young entrepreneurs
to understand, is that
your investors and you as a CEO
don't always have an alignment
in regards to your goal.
And investors need to take care
of their investment.
The CEO needs to take care of the company,
the employees, the management team.
And sometimes that creates a challenge.
Right.
Many times they're aligned
in order to grow the company
because the company is doing well.
Everybody is successful.
But many times
there is a certain amount of friction.
And I think the role
of an independent board member
is to actually play that role
where his incentive is not the investor.
His incentive is not the VC.
His incentive is not necessarily the CEO.
There's one thing that he sees
that he really cares about,
and that's the company.
And being a good independent board member
is like super critical
to the success of the company
because you actually
bring together employees, CEOs,
management team,
and actually the investors
and actually bring them together
on the same path.
Sometimes it's not an easy job,
but you've gotta make sure that
you always think about
what's best for the company.
And that's what a
good independent board member does. And I -
Do you feel a part of the company?
Do you feel like you have
a stake in the company emotionally?
Or do you feel more of an adviser
that is overlooking this operation?
And obviously you have the best interest
in mind for both the CEO and the company,
but how connected are you
to the mission and the values
that the company exudes?
So I'm very connected.
And that basically means that
I would never take
an independent board seat
without investing in the company myself.
Oh, okay.
But that's me personally.
Not every independent board member
does that.
So, why is that?
Why do you do that?
I do that in order to make sure that
it's important to me
to think about the company first.
Okay.
So, that's me.
By the way, I learned things from
an independent board member that I had
when I was in Applause.
His name was ...
He actually sold a company to IBM
for about three billion dollars.
But he was my independent board member.
And he invested in my company
and I learned from him that
if you wanna truly become a
good independent board member
and help the CEOs and the VCs
grow a company,
you've gotta have an incentive
to make the company successful.
And if you put your money
where your mouth is,
that is always very helpful
because you never forget.
And I always invest in those companies.
And I would say I was,
I probably were part of five companies
where I was an independent board member.
And I think I had four very good
successes and one failure,
which is not bad.
It's pretty fantastic,
pretty fantastic statistics.
Wonderful.
Doron, talk to me about Applause.
Writing software is difficult.
"Software is eating the world"
is a quote by Marc Andreessen himself.
What is Applause
and why is it so relevant
as the years go by?
Because it's been here for some time.
Yes. So, Applause has been around
for about 11 years.
I would say when the company got started,
and I'm also the co-founder
of the company,
the idea was really simple at the time.
The idea was
we invest a lot of money
in testing software.
People, process, methodology, tools.
But when software gets
to the hands of real people,
there's still multiple issues
that gets found.
And we always need to remember
that the reason why
we develop software
is in order to serve humans.
Right?
Right.
That's really why we develope software,
why everybody developes software.
And the idea was really simple.
Why aren't we successful?
The point was
we're actually missing a step.
And the step was actually
testing in the wild.
Actually simulating and mimicking
your real users, your real customers.
And that's the way to find issues
that they never found
in a lab environment,
found by automation.
And the idea was simple:
Why don't we build
a global community of test engineers
and test in the wild
on real devices,
real configurations.
At scale, at speed, in real time,
24/7, 365.
And that's actually what we came about.
Indeed we actually built
a technology platform
that on one end side integrates with the
product development life cycle.
... tracking system and CI/CD
and on the other end side
manages a global community of
software tech engineers
which is today more than half a million
community members
from 200 countries and regions worldwide.
And you can think it's a simple idea
meaning you take a software product
an iPhone app, an IOT app,
whatever it is,
and throw it over the wall
to bunch of people.
But it's not really like that
because let's talk about the complexity.
If you take Uber as an example,
they actually match
a driver and a passenger
for a single point in time
for a single ride, single transaction.
We actually match a dedicated team
with a software product
on an ongoing basis
and the team needs to fix
the experience of the software product.
And there's communication
and collaboration,
and it's done in real time 24/7.
So, the technology
and obviously incentives for the testers
in order to align incentives
with what the company is looking for.
So, the complexity is actually really high
from a technology platform perspective.
And I would also say
most of our customers are
big enterprise companies.
So, when you look at your iPhone
or Android device, I am happy to say
that probably 50 or 60%
of the apps that you have out there
are probably tested by Applause.
And that includes companies like
Google and Microsoft and Amazon,
but also big retailers and media companies,
and many types of enterprise companies
that really focus on making
their customers and users successful.
Right. Doron, this concept of
testing in the wild,
I think that's so interesting
because almost every software team
in the world today
has this notion of quality testing.
Both software testing.
Test driven methodology or QA team
that runs and does a 100 manual test cases.
I know in the in the Army,
in 8200 where I served,
we spent days testing every software
to make sure we don't have any errors.
What is the difference between
testing in the wild and the notion of
doing tests in-house within your company?
Why is that different?
Yes. So, I think two things
basically happen
if you test in-house,
you actually are testing
in a single location
and you have a limited
amount of devices that you test it on.
It's also very tiring to test, right.
It's very repetitive type of task
that you're not actually doing,
journeys and use cases,
and exploratory like a real user would do.
And that's exactly what we do.
Take the most simple example,
take HBO Go.
Can you test HBO Go from China?
From Vietnam?
No, they don't even have
distribution rates over there -
And these are average regular people
sitting at home who can sign up
and have incentives to go
and just download the app
and play with it.
And they can perhaps go through
a list of tasks
or they can just do a free for all
and for every bug that they find,
they get some incentive for it, right?
That's correct.
But it's not only like that.
It's actually a dedicated team.
And we actually do automatic matching.
So if I'm any type of company,
let's say I'm WalMart testing my
Walmart application.
You want to make sure
that you test it in areas where
there is a Walmart.
You wanna make sure
that you do customer journey.
Do, order from your mobile phone
and pick it up at the store.
You want to make sure
that the whole experience
actually works well.
And that's what's really being tested.
And you wanna make sure
that you test it on devices
that are in North America
in central locations where they rolled out
pick up in store.
You actually wanna really simulate
and mimic the users,
but you also want to have good testers
that have experience and expertise
and have them dedicated to the work
on an ongoing basis and have incentive
to actually look for the things
that you care about
because many times when
you hire a team in India,
they just run through test cases.
Right.
This is a little bit more than that
because there's incentives to actually find fault
that the customer is looking for
so he can fix it
and basically launch a
better product into the market.
But this isn't instead of the QA
on the team or internal testing, right?
This is as a supplement
to really go the extra mile and say,
"Yes, we have caught 80 or 85%
of the bugs on our end our testing cycles"
but there will inevitably be
10 to 15% out in the wild
because of weird devices,
and screen resolutions,
and Wi-Fi and country VPNs, right?
Well, the honest truth is that
they actually started like that.
It started that augmentation to ...
but as we evolved and matured
as a company,
today we manage the complete cycle
for a lot of our customers
on an ongoing basis.
Right.
So, I would say that both
models are available.
If you wanna have your own team
and kind of augment it, that's fine.
If you wanna have us take ownership
of everything including automation,
So, today, over time, we built
technology that allows you
to do automation,
that allows you to do accessibility
testing which is supercritical
for every mobile
and web application today.
If you wanna make sure
that you do voice testing.
You wanna make sure that you do
data collection for AI and ML engine at
very high quality
and then test the engine.
So, we actually today do all that.
And I think one very important thing
to note is that
many teams look at automation
and manual testing as separate.
We actually look at the very holistic way,
look at it in a very holistic way.
So, automation and manual testing
in the wild
and test case execution
and exploratory testing
need to work in harmony.
So, our platform today
is a true digital quality platform
that allows you
to actually bring all of it together
into a single metric
and helps you make better decisions
when are you really ready to launch.
Okay. Wonderful.
Doron, tell me what is it like
being the CEO of a company
that's 11 years old, a SAS company.
I mean, how do you dedicate a vision
to a company that's 11 years old.
Where is it at now?
And how has your role as the CEO
transitioned over the years
now that it's profitable
and you're just enjoying it?
Yeah. So, when the company started
remember we started from an idea.
Like we went and raised money
from a PowerPoint
that's basically from a concept.
The ompany today is completely different.
Right.
Way over $100 million in revenue.
It's a profitable company.
We have 500 employees.
Offices in multiple locations worldwide.
So, first of all, it's great to see,
but I think it's very important to know
that vision is something
that evolves over time. Right.
You always need to have a North Star
that you basically go and aspire to be.
So if the beginning it was,
in the wild testing
we wanna be this augmentation staff
and then we wanna make sure that
we wanna be a team.
And we wanna make sure that
that all the testing is done.
And now the vision is a true
digital quality platform.
The vision is evolving over time. Right.
As the company matures.
And I think one of the most important
positions and jobs
that the CEO and founder needs to do
is make sure that everybody
is aligned on a vision.
And that basically means
the management team, the employees, the investors,
they're all aligned on a vision.
And from my personal perspective,
as long as it's exciting
and I keep learning
and the company's still scaling and growing,
then I'm enjoying myself, right.
And I would say that today
Applause is not the same
than it was a year ago
and it's definitely
not the same than it was 5 years ago.
And as long as that keeps on growing
as a company and doing that
and being the real leader
in the market,
and I enjoy what I am doing.
I love it. Is there still room
for risk taking or
or is there more of an approach
of don't fix what ain't broken?
Oh, you gotta take risks.
You gotta take risks.
First of all, I think
at a certain point in time,
some companies actually do the mistake
of stop being innovative
Right.
And I think once you do that
the potential of a spiral roll down
is very very high.
because
once you're successful
Once you're successful
you're gonna have competitors
and some of them are good smart people
that you kind of paved the path to them
and if you mess it up,
they're gonna take your spot. Right?
So, you've gotta continue to innovate.
And we put every year,
we have what's called Applause Labs.
And that's part of our engineering team.
And all they do is think about new ideas
and new concepts.
And we're rolling out new functionality,
new features, new capabilities,
and new product.
Today you can bring your own team
as part of the Applause platform.
So, let's say you have a team
of business users that you wanna test.
And you have the data
in one location. You can do that
There's many new functionality like
low code no code automation that we're launching
to the market which is
a brand new concept
around automation of software.
So, the company is investing quite a lot
in what would be innovative.
It's very important to also make sure
that the innovation
is around your vision. Right?
You need to continue
to strive to your vision
otherwise the forces are not aligned.
And it sounds like a huge responsibility
that you're taking being a global leader
and what it means to have quality testing
and quality assurance over products.
And it's almost an innate responsibility
that you're taking on
as you're continuously thinking
what is the next step for quality.
How is the world transitioning to testing,
especially as software is developing.
New languages are coming up.
New technologies are arising constantly.
You know, over the past five years,
IOT has completely exploded.
Now there is gonna be AI models
on device all around us.
And this is gonna bring new challenges
I'm sure to testing. New edge cases
that nobody had thought of.
And you ... this responsibility
of making the leap forward. Right?
Yeah, and by the way
those challenges today
exist already, right
I mean, let me give you another,
and better we do all that type of testing.
Let me give you another analogy.
So, you look at Voice, for example.
And you look at the evolution of Voice.
Voice is actually growing much
more than what mobile grew
because of two reasons:
One, it's a natural way for a human
to interact with software.
And two, it's completely
device independent.
It doesn't matter
if you interact with your phone,
or with Android or with IOS
or with your TV,
or with your fridge.
It's a natural way to interact.
And that's actually growing
exponentially faster than what
mobile apps used to grow.
And that basically means that companies
are investing in voice applications.
Right.
And we do a bunch of testing
around voice applications.
And we work with some
of the infrastructure players
like Amazon and Google around
testing their infrastructure for voice
because Alexa is becoming
more sophisticated. Right?
And there's many other companies
that are investing in voice infrastructure,
and AI and ML infrastructure.
So actually, it's very exciting to be
part of that and help those companies
create a better digital experience
and a better world for all of us.
Very very cool.
Doron, right before we leave,
20 minutes they always end so quick,
but I somehow I feel like
I'm learning so much through this.
So, thank you for your time.
I need three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
And again, thank you for doing this.
You have 500 people that you're managing
across so many different places.
And it's just inspiring to see how
you helped grow this company
from a PowerPoint idea.
Seven years later to this
global leader on quality and testing.
And as an engineer myself, obviously,
I know how critical this is
and how difficult it is to really
feel confident in software that you wrote.
So really incredible to hear
what you guys are doing.
Yes.
So, I'll give you a few words.
So, persistent. Right.
So, be persistent.
Believe.
Okay. As an entrepreneur,
you go through very hard times
and you've gotta believe in your vision
and basically what you're doing.
And lastly, it's love doing.
Right.
You're doing it
not because of money
not because of anything,
you're doing it because you love doing
So, I think these are the three, I would say,
concept that I really love.
I love it. And on the side,
you're still investing right,
in early stage companies,
also through J-Ventures,
but also through,
Are you still sitting
on board seats right now?
I'm actually sitting on a board seat
of a company
which I actually can't announce
because they haven't launched yet.
But it's one of my passions.
So, I actually enjoy biking
and it's a company
that is involved in the biking industry.
So, it's gonna announce
later this summer
and once it's announced
I'll gladly share
But that's that's the only
company I'm on the board of,
other than Applause, of course.
Of course.
Doron, toda raba.
Thank you very, very much.
And best of luck with everything.
Thank you for your time.
Thank you. My pleasure.
Take care.